on gagnait combien à la présentation de
Télématin Laurent euh en net j'étais à
6005 6000 euros 500 par mois
c'est pas fou pour un présentateur de
télé sur france télé quand on sait ce
que gagne notre présentateurs je fais
partie de la maison et une échelle de
salaire je suis rédacteur en chef niveau
je sais pas quoi machin d'accord mais
c'est le moment vous avez gagné le plus
votre vie ah bah oui c'est forcément
vous allez gagner combien la retraite le
robiniolas je pense que c'est dans les
[Applaudissements]
Bruno Le Maire à savoir que il est en
train de nous parler après déduction
d'impôts après moi je pense que ce
serait plus aux alentours des 10000
alors il nous a il nous faut
pas faire un mytho il a dit 6500
tu crois qu'il allait gagner combien on
croyais qu'on lui donne 5000 euros
bah ça lui fait 5000 donc il a dit
j'ai pas dit que c'était un mytho j'ai
dit que il remasterait la réalité pour
que ça paraisse plus bas oui qu'est-ce
qu'il y a non il dit c'est en net c'est
les salaires il y a une grille salariale
des rédacteurs en chef déjà il est
rédacteurs en chef parce qu'il a négocié
il n'aurait pu être qu'un animateur donc
il négocie pour être payé plus haut ce
sont les salaires par exemple de
rédacteur en chef de la presse écrite
donc ça correspond tout à fait ça fait
déjà ça fait 10000 ans
pour présenter une quotidienne sur une
grosse chaîne c'est un tout petit
salaire en vrai un présentateur d'une
tranche info sur une chaîne info ça
gagne entre 8 et 12000 euros un prime
les salaires tiens des animations infos
c'est 800 toi quelqu'un qui est en
journée à part les stars quelqu'un qui
en journée entre 8 et 12000 après une
TNT ça a baissé c'est entre 1500 et 5000
après les quotidiennes ça dépend des
personnalités mais sur une grosse chaîne
après une tf10000 150 max mais là
franchement 6500 € brut pour être
irrédacteur en chef présentateur net
donc ça fait 8000 brut 8005 c'est
beaucoup mais c'est pas énorme pour une
quotidienne franchement c'est merci de
votre concours
non vraiment Bernard Montiel toi qui a
gagné les sommes astronomiques sur TF1
mais arrêtez de dire ça on va me
demander des sous après mais on va
déjeuner différemment toi qui a amassé
un petit trésor de guerre et euh 500 €,
c'est quoi oui de toute façon ce garçon
est honnête
je suis pisser les salaires de France
privé on gagnait plus évidemment parce
que c'était le privé donc il fait des ce
qu'il voulait mais France Télévisions
c'est quand même l'argent public donc il
est normal que les tarifs soient c'est
déjà beaucoup d'argent combien par mois
vidéo gag ça dépend par mois
non oui non on était très bien payé oui
c'était c'est que ça cartonnait
150000 € par mois 350 000 francs à
l'époque c'était des Francs oui 150000
francs par mois je l'ai fait je l'ai
fait pendant 14
grosso modo mais je peux regarder ça
fait 150000 euros parce qu'en vérité
c'est pareil aujourd'hui 1 € 20 francs
franchement ça doit faire ça
un peu moins que 250000 € quand même
mais on tournait on tournait tous ses
émissions et puis surtout ça cartonnait
pour voir deux chiens qui pète et un
chat qui franchement je suis désolé je
vous conseille un jour quand vous avez
un concept de ce genre non mais tu as
raison que j'avais vu aux États-Unis
j'ai trouvé formidable j'avais proposé à
mujote c'est toi qui l'ai proposé
America's en vidéo tu sais c'est black
la configuration aux États-Unis en
Arabie Saoudite
non non mais c'était formidable moi
j'avais adoré le concept et c'était non
ça a duré 14 ans quand même c'était très
bien payé 14 ans à 14 ans 50000 boules
par mois non mais non au début pas du
tout attends quand j'ai démarré mais
arrêtez de faire des calculs un peu
gênant parce que c'est faux quand j'ai
démarré il était pas question de ça
c'est un moment manque de peau
ça a tellement au début ça a marché
c'était pas très bien tu as pris 21 bars
c'est pas ça du tout
j'ai fait part 10 mois 150000 ça fait un
million et demi par mois soit 14 21
millions toi aide-moi
avec une calculette dans les mains voilà
mais c'est pas du tout ça
que tu as acheté la Villa euh au Pilat
les oliviers
de 30 ans non
tu te fous de la gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je t'aime beaucoup si je peux terminer
mon truc quand j'ai signé ma maison
c'est en 1989
et j'avais un crédit sur 30 ans à 11,5
12% d'intérêt mais oui vous rappelez pas
de ça
heureusement grâce à TF1 j'ai pu
rembourser le crédit cette maison
j'avais payé cette maison mais un
million de francs je peux tout noter
la maison du Pilat tu l'as pas connu toi
donc j'ai acheté un million de francs
j'avais pas un rond je voulais dire
modeste et tant mieux voilà je suis
heureux mais j'ai payé un million de
francs donc 30 ans j'ai pas un rond même
pas pour investir à me donner un peu
mais ils m'ont fait confiance parce que
je commençais à être connu à la télé ça
a duré j'ai payé au bout de 10 ans j'ai
tout payé j'étais content mais donc là
pour la maison là ouais laquelle la
nouvelle mais quelles nouvelles
la nouvelle maison tu l'as payé avec moi
avec mon cul
avec la plus-value de la maison de 89
est-ce qu'on peut garder un peu de privé
dans sa vie il y a moins d'argent
aujourd'hui à la télévision qui a 10 ans
ou 20 ans bah oui global oui oui je suis
pas d'accord avec ça ah si si si sauf
vous non mais arrête moi non mais non
mais non mais les animateurs à l'époque
vous voyez nous on présentait un prime
le samedi soir sans toucher 15 20 000
balles c'est fini ça c'est fini et en
plus nous ce qu'on faisait de bien c'est
qu'on faisait des signatures dans les
magasins de meubles et tout ça ouais
j'ai adoré il a Ichimoku mais ah bah
alors j'allais partout et j'adore
l'électroménager
il est moins payé que par exemple un
Jean-Pierre Foucault à l'époque non ça
dépend du contrôle technique
il y avait trois chaînes les mecs tout
le monde regardait bien sûr
rappeler les choses c'est pourquoi vous
êtes payé autant à une époque c'est
parce que vous ramenez la pub c'était
les annonceurs qui payaient c'était même
pas la chaîne on avait des annonceurs
partout et ça a été le début d'ailleurs
du marketing image avec les marques
auprès des émissions et c'était surtout
les marques qui nous payaient comme ça